well it also brings me back to your
documentary with your former classmate
Caleb yeah and you know he talked about
in the film I hope I'm not giving
anything away but that once he got this
cancer diagnosis that he realized that
he and his wife had been living for the
weekends hmm and I think that's it that
was just really that just really struck
me because I have to tell you I was
afraid to watch the film because I was
afraid was gonna make me depressed and
so but I did and it was really an
eye-opener because it was really about
them noticing their lives and realizing
whether there's a cancer diagnosis or
not that time slips away and what are we
living for is it just to buy the next
big toy you know I'm thrilled you saw it
that way because that's really the film
I intended to make so I'm excited you
saw it that way yes I really thought a
lot about time with a few things about
cancer and that was one of the things
that really struck me especially now
that I've even hit my mid-twenties you
know I'm 26 and for some people at my
age I've done a lot more and some people
a lot less but I think very much about
what my pathway is going to be as a
filmmaker the things that I want to make
and the things that I want to do and
when I had the opportunity to tell Caleb
and Jada's story it struck me that they
too were thinking about that a lot and
that they were in this nine to five job
that they were living this 925 life they
were newlyweds and then this thing
happens that completely changes the
trajectory of their life stage four
cancer that could mean a diagnosis of
death what do you do with that what do
you do if your life and if you live how
do you move forward from that and make
modifications to the choices you make
you know I had that experience when I
was 13 when my dad died unexpectedly but
most people in their 20s that's not when
you're supposed to face death in the eye
you're supposed to be living your life
and going music festivals and going to
clubs you're supposed to be having fun
but not sitting down and facing reality
and i think that the moment that we all
can face reality is the moment that we
can really think about where we were
alive
go and with a few things about cancer I
really wanted to do that I think to
losing a parent at an early age turns
you into an old soul where you you you
know more mature for years did you see
that turning point with the two of them
absolutely I saw that a weekend to it it
was incredible there was there's a
moment in the film that I think is
pretty powerful where they start talking
about what they want their lives to look
like and I think that that was their
moment when they realized it there was a
moment in the hospital that's someone
that was supposed to have a good
prognosis they were like a patient in
another room that was nearby those about
the same age died suddenly and they
realized in that moment you know this
isn't really a game this is this is real
and that's not to say that wasn't real
for them before that moment of course it
was but it was in that moment that they
really got to see firsthand the
fragility of life and how temporary it
can be and the moment that we all can
acknowledge that is the moment that a
lot of us can free ourselves from the
confines of what we think is possible
once we do that I think then anything
can become possible for us because then
we realize our time is limited and the
choices we make directly impact what we
are capable of doing
you